would you say it has not been fantastic
it has not been marvelous
or fantastic or amazing or spider-gram
i'm here with tom and nina to talk about
which actors and actresses we most want
to join the mcu
nina which actors and actresses do you
most want to join the mcu
well one of these was just gifted to me
a couple of days ago
um because you know julia louis dreyfus
just recently joined the mcu and as many
people know she's the star of
many tv shows but most recently and
notably she
starred on beep and one of her co-stars
sam richardson said that he wants to
play beast
in the mcu because he thinks that beast
is his veep character richard split
but huge and with blue hair oh that
rocks and i love sam richardson he's
great on veep if you're not familiar
with him you're really missing out on
him he's also
uh he works with tim robinson a lot and
was on my favorite show of
my life i think you should leave and
they work together on detroiters
i would love to see sam richardson join
the mcu um and that got me thinking of
like other comedians i think ben
schwartz would be really funny in the
mcu but i don't know where he would go
like improvisers like lauren lapkus
would be really funny as well
yeah i was just thinking about like you
know the mcu is known for being
funny right i mean james gunn and and
take away tt especially like
have very distinct senses of humor and
that really shines through in their
movies
and then i was also like wouldn't it be
weird if like timothy chalamet just
popped up in the mcu it was like an a as
like a really
like emo teen alien i wouldn't say no to
beautiful who could look at timothy i
was thinking about like you know
florence pugh just joined and she was in
little women with timothy shalom and
sarah ronan and
i'm like hmm laura dern let's throw her
in the mix too
i don't think timothy chalamet could
play laura dern i don't think he has
arranged for it
well i mean that's no one can play laura
dern except for laura darren
that's right but yeah i mean i know i
was just all over the map with that but
you know
obviously more comedians is never gonna
hurt sam richardson definitely should
play beast i hope he already got the
offer to be honest with you but
yeah i mean let's let's let some of
these prestige actors like
like laura dern or tiffany show me have
a little fun okay
i haven't never heard anybody
say that more comedians couldn't hurt
before but maybe that's just the error
that we're in
[Music]
i think you've just been doing stand up
for too long done
i haven't been doing stand-up for not
long enough
so tom what are some of the actors and
actresses you want to see added to the
mcu
first off it seems like a crime that
rowan atkinson hasn't been a part of
this yet oh
good one rowan atkinson wow thank you
very much yes i mean number one
i don't think that we've seen enough
straight white men in the mcu
i think that he could really fill a
vacuum there also
right just the no it that that does seem
weird right like that seems like an easy
paycheck that he could have picked up
yeah
yeah yeah he doesn't have to be a main
character he's just like he's a
background nova corp
like standing up too straight and not
approving of these guardians of the
galaxy
i mean something like that he could do
something kind of like um
i mean i never enjoy bringing up the
film love actually personally but
in that movie he just kind of floats
around on the fringe and like interacts
with different characters and it's
the best part of the movie totally you
know like yeah he could do something
like that in the mcu and i would be on
board
i'm down for it yeah he could just come
back as the same character he played in
the tall guy
that's fantastic so yeah
that'd uh right now i'm uh
just bonkers for the the hbo
adaptation of doom patrol that they're
doing if they wanted to bring the entire
cast of that show in to play like
their analog x-men characters
i like that i'd watch it yeah yeah no
problem yeah so
so brendan fraser would be who who's the
analog in robot man
it's got to be wolverine right you bring
him in as like the angry
break stuff guy yeah is he canadian i
think he's canadian isn't it he is
canadian so it wouldn't even be
appropriation yeah and he's yeah no he's
got his memory all [ __ ] with like
that's yeah no that's wolverine so that
works
yeah that'd be cool i mean i'm never
against
watching uh timothy uh
uh i'm fort yeah timothy shalom
justice for timothy chalamet oh sorry
patrol no i've been watching the version
of doom patrol where
timothy shalom just live streams himself
watching it like eating handfuls of
warriors
i mean now that we now that we're on the
subject of doom patrol alan tudyk right
um is that how you say alan tudyk how
has he not been in the mcu yet
he's he does a lot of work for disney
too and is isn't he actually
starring on a tv show right now where he
plays an alien in a human form he's
starting in 80 tv shows and he's in like
every cartoon
yeah every cartoon version of a
superhero thing he's
yeah no this is uh is this wonky do you
think we could get him and gina torres
in there together somehow i'm i feel
relatively positive
[Applause]
but that's suicide squad right nathan
fillion was going to be
wonder man in movie posters as an easy
no yeah i think that all got
cut but he has like cameos in the
guardians movies because i think he's
friends with james gunn
because he is friends with james he's a
prison he's a prisoner
in the jail he's the one who threatens
uh
peter and then groot sticks his fingers
up his nose
and just decimates him that's nathan
it's just his
voice i don't know if he did any motion
capture work for it but it is his voice
yeah he's like back in the days friends
with uh with james gunn he did
because he did slither but he also did
uh pg porn yeah exactly
wow hilarious yeah i didn't have that
that's a funny video yeah nathan philly
tiny little mcu cameo dude
that doesn't seem like the easiest way
yeah nerd cred
exactly that we could do right is just
get the entire cast of firefly
right together to bring everyone back
now that joss whedon is out of the
picture just bring
just make firefly part of the yeah yeah
yeah fireplace mcu cannon yeah
i mean disney owns it now right right
yeah it's fox
bring it back anyway we're getting off
the opera we've gotten off topic so
uh for me the the two actors that i i
wrote a few different actors down that i
really like
um but the two that i was happiest about
i also
got their roles in mind and it's uh
richard iowa
yeah from the i.t crowd i love him cool
i want him to play mr fantastic
in a fantastic format interesting okay
good america ferreira
from superstore yes and i want her to be
the invisible woman
oh and i want to see what they're like
because richard iwata is is very good at
being intelligent and aloof
and funny and charming all at the same
time and america ferreira is good at
being
tough and caring and powerful and
bringing a bunch of weirdos together to
get stuff done from superstore
great show so i just think that if you
stick those two together
you bring life to these two parts that
in the past
again you know the previous fantastic
four movies
there's some good stuff there's some not
so good stuff but overall i would say
that the dynamic between
mr and ms fantastic has not necessarily
been
all that interesting or exciting would
you say it has
not been fantastic it has not been
marvelous
or fantastic or amazing or spider-man
um but i think that now i'm not
necessarily saying that these two actors
have like such a great chemistry i have
no idea
but they're they're they're interesting
choices yes are choices that i don't
think
i've ever would have thought of if i
hadn't been asked this question
and i think you know i would love to see
something you know everyone talks about
john krasinski and emily blunt as
as the two leads of the fantastic four
and it's like sure
why not yeah fine okay yeah i mean that
would work yeah
yeah it's fun it's fine like they're
great if
if they got cast tomorrow i'd be like
yeah cool yeah okay i actually don't
watch you that movie just watched quiet
place for the first time this weekend uh
because i am
really frightened easily frightened so
that was not something i went into
lightly they're very good in it like
yeah
they're great actors and they work
beautifully together obviously so like
yeah i'd be psyched but let's go for
maybe a less obvious choice let's try
something a little different and plus
plus emily blunt recently at least at
the time at the time of this recording
recently was like stop asking me about
it yeah kind of sick of hearing about it
i'm
not i don't think i'm gonna do it so i'm
kind of like all right cool so let's
find
and talk about someone else so let's
make this happen like
richard iowa and america ferrari why not
they're
very really talented people and yeah and
you know you were like i don't know if
they work well together but here's why i
think they might
is they're both um like trained comedic
actors who have worked with
who are really uh their resumes are very
like ensemble-based i mean america
ferreira did the sisterhood of the
traveling pants movie she did ugly betty
she did superstore
richard iawate has done you know like i
t crowd is very much based on like
riffing off one another in the chemistry
right so
they're both people with experience in
working with ensembles and making that
work
so i think they could be great together
and richard iowa has already worked with
disney in the star wars exactly doing
the voice of the voice of that robot
from mandalore the one whose name we all
remember
it's a bunch of numbers it's numbers
that's fine and then he was also
in seoul everybody's name is he was in
seoul i forgot he was in seoul
yeah so i think overall at the very
least
i really i'm excited about that i'm like
in my head now it's already happening
but it's just kind of like like what
would that be like and and he could keep
his british accent i want to hear him
doing an american accent
keep making british who cares like just
just go with it it'd be interesting
can i ask you who would play ben grimm
in your version
i didn't think that far ahead but i do
think you could just get michael
checklist back
can i make a recommendation sure rowan
atkinson
perfect who's going to play the human
torch
probably also wrong yeah he contains
multitudes
yeah oh you know who could be a really
good thing
jesse plemmons oh yeah okay
he's a bigger dude yeah he's he's not
known for his small stature he's he's a
big presence
and he's got he's an incredible actor
he's
super good at everything he does true
you know like
game night is a movie i really like oh i
love game night one of the best
like blockbuster mainstream comedies
like a mainstream comedy that's
legitimately funny he's so funny in that
movie he's so good in that yeah and uh
and he was also in um uh but i'm
thinking of ending things
and he was also in fargo season two and
these are all things he was in
that star trek episode of black mirror
uh uss alistar which is
terrifying he's really good in it yeah
so there you go so go ahead no i just
had a
that you know what we don't have to talk
about but i did just happen to visit the
mafria
get vincent d'onofrio to play ben grimm
i think that that would rock
but there was already the kingpin yeah
i mean that's true i guess yeah but who
cares yeah whatever they've already got
uh copperhead back to be played so
they're right
yeah okay so who's human torch besides
rowan atkinson
second choice i have no idea
i i refuse to even timothy [ __ ]
entertainment
laura we've done it
[Applause]
there it is zoom in on tom's eyes
star wave thanks for joining us please
hit like and subscribe so you don't miss
a single new episode